an American pastor detained in Turkey
for two years is beginning to readjust
to life back here in the United States
pastor Andrew Brunson was charged with
espionage and links to a terrorist
organization in 2016 the indictment
against the pastor says he worked to
convert courage to Christianity in order
to sow discord in Turkey he denies any
wrongdoing a Turkish court sentenced him
to prison on Friday but released him on
time serve Brunson lived in Turkey for
more than 20 years and oversaw a
Presbyterian Church President Trump
welcomed to the White House over the
weekend just after his return pastor
Brunson joins us with his wife Noreen at
the table we're so glad you're here so
glad you're safe welcome home welcome
home indeed so you all had gone to fill
out some paperwork and you were arrested
and told what we were told we were a
threat to national security and would be
deported but then we waited to be
deported and they didn't and eventually
well they kept me for two years and what
were you thinking Andrew when you're
told you were a threat to national
security what were you doing there well
we were very shocked because we had
spent 23 years working very openly
telling people about Jesus helping
refugees things like that so we hadn't
done anything that would harm national
security we were just telling people
about Jesus did you ever think what you
were doing would land you in prison that
it was dangerous
not that it would land us in prison
we're the first ones have experienced
that in Turkey
in a long time ignoring what were they
telling you same thing we were together
so we were arrested together and held
together initially for I was there 13
days and then released suddenly and
after that release though what was that
like a lot of uncertainty not knowing if
I could remain in the country I wanted
to stay with him until this was all done
so just a lot of difficulty a lot of ups
and downs during that time what did you
think was happening to him were you all
able to communicate with each other
during that time what did you think
very little uh-huh very little so you
knew he was safe he was moved there were
just so many question marks what's
happening silence we're not told what's
going on what's going to happen I was
very isolated in prison I was four
some time in solitary confinement and
then in another prison that was quite
overcrowded and though I was accredited
like how well we were a cell for eight
people and had over 20 people there in
the self yes yes and there was very
little contact with the outside so I
could see no rain for example 35 minutes
a week through glass talking by phone
and so she actually is very strong and
had to take me through this emotionally
and spiritually she was the only one I
could receive truth from and so when she
would come in she would encourage me and
that's what would keep me going for the
next week Brunson much has been written
about about you and we followed your
your imprisonment for the past two years
do you believe you were a pawn and what
has been called hostage diplomacy that
the Turkish government held you as part
of an effort to exchange you for another
prisoner here well people have certainly
written that President Trump and also
senator Graham Lindsey Graham told me
that I just had the view from the cell
yeah and I think that even though
whatever reason the Turkish government
was holding us for I believe that God
was involved in this for us because I
think of millions of people who prayed
for Turkey during that time and how God
is bringing blessing out of it were they
interrogating you on a regular basis
were you beaten while you were in prison
how would you know I wasn't meeting the
problem is that I wasn't interrogated so
for the first 18 months I didn't know
why I was in prison did you were you
allowed to have a Bible eventually it
took a while before I could have any
books or Bible but eventually I did have
one is there a passage that got you
through all this
well I read second Timothy a lot where
Paul talks about suffering and finishing
the race well and this is became my
prayer I want to be faithful and endure
and finish well Noreen when you heard he
was getting out of prison how did you
all receive the news that it was over
incredibly relieved we got on our knees
Courthouse yeah didn't care what anybody
thought yeah and us to me three children
who called turkey home for so many years
I want to ask you about your experience
coming home and meeting with the
president in the Oval Office what
the first thing he said to you I think
he probably said welcome home and then
after that yeah I don't really remember
but we Noreen had actually had a dream
about praying for the president before
and so she had that in her heart
so before we went to the White House we
prayed together and said ask God to give
us opportunity to pray for the president
and we asked him if we could do it and
he said yes yes Noreen no so I had a
specific dream specific verses so when
there was the opportunity I knew exactly
what I was supposed to pray over him now
I know you all love turkey yeah in
Isaiah 11 you lived there for 23 years
what is your feeling about the country
now what are you thinking you know we
love the country we love it we love the
people we have dear friends there we
pray for its blessing but you're staying
here we're here for now I don't think we
can go back right now one of the most
hated people in Turkey so and definitely
forgiveness has to be a part of this we
don't have an option not to forgive as
Christians but it is something it's not
easy so we're working through that
there's a big community that's welcoming
you back here and glad that you're back
home thank you so much for joining you
thank you